hey everyone this is jeremy schieffling
from khan academy thanks so much for
joining us in a long running series of
remote learning 101 it's gone on a
little longer than we expected at the
beginning back in march but we're happy
to serve you with whatever is most of
interest what we've heard from a lot of
teachers across the country is that yeah
technology is hard and academics are
hard right now but motivation and
engagement sparking that fundamental
curiosity and passion for learning is
really the toughest thing to sum when
everyone's feeling a little down
and so into that void has stepped this
amazing khan academy ambassador laura
lagasse who is an incredible sixth grade
teacher in southern california
and who even before this crisis started
i'm motivating her students with a very
special part of khan academy that was
built in collaboration with pixar which
is called pixar in a box
basically an online curriculum that's
not about calculus or algebra or apus
history but about how do you tell really
amazing stories using both human
ingenuity and technology
and so i would love for you to learn
from laura about her experience and her
recommendations
and i want to give you a little bit of
an extra bonus today in the spirit of
pixar and innovation
we're going to try a new way of asking
questions for these webinars
so instead of just asking questions in
the question box and then waiting to see
if your question will be answered we're
actually going to use a new tool which
you can find at con.co
con
i will chat that into the chat area
right now
and what you will find when you get
there is a list of questions coming in
from teachers across the country
that you can not only add to but you can
also upvote so if you see a question
that you're really excited about just go
ahead and give it a thumbs up and those
will rise to the top and those are the
ones that will turn to lower first to
make sure they get priority answers
so that being said laura we're so
excited to have you here today um thank
you again for sharing your expertise in
the midst of everything else going on
take a moment to tell us about your own
educational adventure and how you got to
this moment
well i'm uh a teacher here in southern
california i've been teaching about uh
20 years now and um i teach at uh in
victor elementary school district
at a school called galileo academy and
i've been
there teaching i taught third grade
there in sixth grade i'm is what i'm
currently teaching right now
that's awesome and tell us how things
are going like how is the remote
learning going for you what are you
learning along the way
well i've
become much more techno technological
uh we've been really
doing a lot of zoom classes and um it's
been really great um i'm able to see the
kids still and the kids are able to see
me and
i'm still able to give them some
a lot of different lessons today we even
took a virtual tour of the uh great wall
of china so it was pretty neat yeah
that's awesome well clearly i can tell
that you're really focused on that
engagement and motivation piece as well
as the technology piece
so why don't you tell us a little bit
more about pixar in a box like what is
it and why did you use it in your
classroom in the first place
well um one of the reasons why i started
using it i actually started out as an
elective
we were able to choose each one of us
were able to choose an elective
something that we really enjoyed doing
and and not something that i really
enjoyed doing doing
um i really think that pixar is in the
box is um the art of storytelling by
storytellers
which is pretty fantastic and so the
last couple of years i thought
this is such a fantastic
um
these lessons are just amazing that i'm
gonna actually use them in my writing
block rather than just using them as an
elective and the kids um absolutely
enjoy it they really have blossomed as
writers and um i really they really
enjoy the process too
that's awesome and so tell us how you
typically use it with your students like
how do you roll it out how do you get
them excited about it um well we usually
do lessons per day but say for example
the very first lesson so we'll go to the
art of storytelling
and in the art of storytelling
they it it's just so fantastic all of
those um different lessons are
just all about the storytelling so the
first thing that i like to do is i'd
like to show
a pixar short what's amazing is pixar
has so many fantastic shorts and they
are short and
it's so great for the kids to be able to
tell back the story and they'll be able
to use those to
help tell us their stories so we start
with
we are storytellers i don't think that
the kids realize what great storytellers
they truly are they just don't know how
to tell that story
or
you know in a pit and they learn how to
do it in a pixar way so um first they
learn
what amazing storytellers they are in
the first lesson
um it talks about uh the characters and
the unique perspective of characters and
and um
what what we do is it's so relatable to
the kids because
once we watch the videos because that's
another really important piece there's
always a video on there and
pixar has
allowed us to see a lot of the different
stories that
come from people who actually work at
pixar that they are able to share their
stories about how they became
storytellers
so
then what it asks the student to do is
then it allows the student to
self-reflect but what's great is most of
these kids have already seen these pixar
movies so they're gonna say they're
they'll ask you
pick your three favorite okay now let's
apply what we've learned so
if
there are
like for example in the first activity
it's about you know the emotions and
it's about really starting to try to
express a memory that they have
so
they'll take it and they'll
put it in the same concept as that
memory is a story that i can expand on
so that's what it first it asks the kids
to actually
draw on their own
um experiences to be able to write those
tell those stories which they soon find
out that they are now storytellers
and then we work into um
just the structure of the story or um
that i love the what-if activities um
in one of them the what have this
happened or that happened and what's
fantastic is you can take um say the
incredibles and then i'll ask the kids
well
who asked what if
what is that what if they asked and
they'll be able to tell me exactly what
if there were superheroes that couldn't
be superheroes anymore well so there's
your story and that's how you can start
it
and then after that we'll work into
character um the kids will
start creating their characters which is
really fantastic because
once they really get
their character developed because we
spend a lot of time on developing that
one character
so once they get the character developed
using the internal and external
characteristics they have to draw the
character they have to tell me who is
this
what what do they have a lisp do they
limp you know and so they have to really
define their characters really well
and so once they can define that
character they can then
put the character into uh a world so
then we talk about setting okay
let's go ahead and we'll talk about um
what kind of world do you want um to act
or to to live in and i love that one
piece where it talks about the wants
versus needs because it's an an amazing
way to start the story they can what
does your character want and what do
they need to do
to be able to go um
and get what they what they want
um and then after we get our character
we want to know you know um
what's happening to the character what
are their stakes you know those kinds of
things then we start looking into the
story structure
which is where the kids really start to
develop their um
their story itself
the one thing that's absolutely amazing
is this story's fine this story's fine
is just something that gets their jesus
really flowing the once upon a time
every day until one day and then because
of that because of that because of that
until finally
and um it's a great way to start the
story sometimes what we'll do in class
is i'll put up the story spine and i say
okay kids
tell me once upon a time and we'll do it
in a group and then the kids will tell
me once upon and then i said okay now
every day what did they do and then
somebody will tell me this that or the
other thing
and then we'll have a class story that
we can repeat and we just have a really
good time with that because sometimes
they turn out pretty funny you could
even do that over zoom these days have
that sort of like class wide story
building
and then after we um work through the
story spine
i love that
the um the spine then turns into three
different acts
so then we have act one and then we have
the three
there's act one beginning middle and
then act one is the once upon a time
every day until one until one day so
then we work through our act one and
then we go on to act two which is the
because of because of because of
and we've worked through that and um
they get their middle meet part of the
story and then finally
we'll go on to act three
and that's until finally and then ever
since then and then they have a story
which is really fantastic
and then after that what we do is then
we'll start storyboarding our our story
so we'll work through that and and they
can see what their story is going to
look like
and then once they have their story
we were talking a little bit earlier
about
then they have
then they really get excited about
writing their story into a script
so what we then do is we go to there's
an
extension in um chrome that is umi
script
and the kids can download this into
their chromebooks and they can actually
write a script
so
they end up having a complete stories
full script and sometimes we talk about
we're doing this and we're going to go
from beginning script to screen and and
um so sometimes if we end up being able
to have a little bit more time we can
maybe record it or do a live action or
sometimes they can do claymation and do
a stop motion and so they get a complete
story
but the other wonderful thing about this
we've been talking about narrative for
for a while here
this also i have used in expository
which has been really great we will
study something like the ancient
cultures
and so what we'll do is
i will give them a prompt and tell them
okay
now you are the character
in this ancient culture so now you can
then
they have to do the research on their
ancient culture they have to find out
everything there is to know about that
culture because they have to be able to
write the setting for that and then
they can have an adventure in the
meantime they're also learning
how to write an expository to be able to
show what an ancient culture or even
scientists they can become scientists
too
that's awesome yeah i have to tell you
like i am super impressed because not
only is everything you shared the kind
of stuff that i think any student would
love to work on during normal times
that's especially the kind of material
that a student could work on even in
these very strange times
whether it's with the class or resume or
on their own through assignments
um yeah
that being said i know there are a ton
of questions coming in and you want to
remind folks if you want to ask those
questions it's khan.com pixar con
and if you don't mind laura i'd love to
start at the top with some of the top
questions coming in
okay so i think this is kind of the
elephant in the room at this point which
is laura's a sixth grade teacher
but do you have any recommendations as
far as like would this work for younger
elementary would you recommend it all
the way up to high school like who is
this really for
well i'm actually going to be uh next
year i'm going to be doing third grade
and i am going to use it in my third
grade class
i think this can be used for all ages if
you're in kindergarten in first grade
you can do it as a directed instruction
and they do it a talk through in
kindergarten and first grade and even
second grade
once you get to third grade i think this
is really something that they can
absolutely do as well
um when you reach the sixth grade it's
just gonna be a little bit more
sophisticated writing they're gonna have
a little bit more um
the language is going to look a little
bit different but this can be used i
would suggest in kindergarten first and
maybe even second for it to be a whole
class direct and maybe write a story all
together
but third through six it works out
wonderfully
great and we'll also mention we've
talked mostly about the storytelling
element but there are a number of
technical sections focused on animation
and visual design and all that
and those are actually recommended for
fifth grade all the way through high
school with some of the chances to
really um apply advanced offerings if
your students are hungry for that so
definitely serves a wide range
yes yes the um i use the animation in um
in my sixth grade class
but some of my kids will come and tell
me oh uh we've already done this you
know we did this when i was in fourth
grade or we did this when i was in fifth
grade so
um it depends on
if the kids really love to
just really go in there and try and use
it
very cool and then in terms of actually
finding it i'll send out this link again
but it's basically
um right here in your chat and if you
ever have any trouble hunting it down
just flat out type pixar into the search
box and there you go
okay so
um next question that was coming in
is that unit that you described with
storytelling all the way from coming up
with inspiration to building a finished
script
how long does it typically take laura
well
it depends on the group
and
i think it's really important to when
the kids are really
um working hard and they're really um
they are so interested in these things
to take as much time
as the kids want to take um i typically
will do a lesson a day but there's quite
a few times when i'll take like the
character development sometimes i'll
take maybe two to three days because we
really want to
get that character really down so
we can put him or her into uh or it into
a whole bunch of different situations
so
i would typically do it um maybe a
lesson every two days or so the first
couple of lessons are going to take
maybe you know an hour
but as you work through it and start
getting into the meat of it
um the acts
the three acts that's going to take a
little bit longer maybe two to three
weeks to get through that
um but it's typically you can we work on
trimesters so typically in a trimester i
can i can have all the lessons finished
that's great so it sounds like if a
teacher started right now depending on
when their school schedule goes through
they could probably finish it up by the
end of the school year
kind of a nice thing to head into the
summer with
yes yes i think so
great
um now going back to the sort of
mathematical piece that we alluded to
the more technical side of things
can you talk about how that works what
that looks like
how you may incorporate math into some
of that
well that's mostly for the ones that are
when you look at the pixar in the box
when you're looking at
um there's with the animation they are
um working through uh math with that in
the artistry so they're just learning
how to plot and how to program how to
do the animation use
how they're using the animation so
really in the animation
they're
that's where they're using the
mouthpiece there
we don't do it as much
um but uh they the kids get right in
there and and with the animation
there is so there are so many tutorials
in there that actually show them exactly
what to do
um they um
they
plotted out for the kids and it's so
exciting with the one the one that
you're showing around now with a
bouncing ball they get so excited when
they get the bouncing ball um but most
of the kids will go right in there and
um and plot it themselves
very cool and then just sort of um
expand upon what we were talking about
before
for each of these more technical
sections there's both an introduction
and then a more advanced mathematical
section so if you have fifth graders you
can start with the intro and stop there
if you have middle or high schoolers you
can even go all the way to the end
exactly
great
um what do you think about this as a
whole course versus a supplement if it
goes back to that elective versus
integrated approach
well i have to say that when i did it as
an elective i only had an hour maybe a
couple of days a week and um i the kids
wanted more more more and because they
really enjoyed it um they also
enjoy watching the pixar movies in short
so everybody wanted to be in the
in that particular
elective
but um i think that this is such an
incredible program uh pixar in the box
that
it just it helps the student so much
with their writing and their writing
block i think it's just i
use it in my writing block and i will i
will continue to use it in my writing
block for my whole class from now on
because um
i just think um
the quality
of their writing that's coming out is
fantastic and then when they write in in
the scripts they also start learning
about dialogue and they also start
learning about
um they learn about how to place the
action and and those sorts of things and
i just like
i would recommend doing it as a writing
block
wonderful
um i know folks are asking about google
classroom which is something that you
mentioned to me before we got started
here what do you recommend there as far
as the integration
well
i really have to say um khan academy has
done an amazing and pixar um together
i've done an amazing job with creating
um the pixar in the box when the lessons
so the lessons are just right there for
you but then what i would do is i would
go ahead and create a google classroom
and then you can share that with your
students and that gives your students
an opportunity to start
adding all of the lessons there so you
can see all the different things they're
doing um i've had quite a few students
what they'll do is they'll take pictures
of their character with them side by
side and and they'll send that to me
um you can have
each you can separate your google
classroom into different
activities
um start with the um storytelling
activity one two three four and then and
then work it that way and then you're
able to see what the kids are able to um
to to create when you're there and then
we also do you know our distance
learning zoom meetings and kids are able
to share all of their information that
way too but i think google classroom is
probably one of the best ways to
get some assignments and be able to give
your kids some feedback on how well
they're doing that's great so we do
something as simple as take that url
right out of the assignment or the
exercise and then paste it into an
assignment in google classroom
that's it
okay cool
that's awesome
um
as far as a teacher guide obviously it's
going to feel a little overwhelming at
first because it's such a big piece of
content
any sort of resources you found that are
useful for like digging in and making
those first steps
well
again
when you're going um to the
pixar in the box
what i would suggest doing is just doing
looking at that educator's guide and um
it really will explain a lot of the um
what's behind pixar on a box and how the
lessons were created and
and i would just go through each one of
the lessons
and teachers are just amazing kinds of
people they always take things and they
do it and make it their own some of the
things that i have done i have
added a little bit to
their learning um so really look at it
and try to make it your own you might
see something to go oh this is fantastic
that's why i added writing scripts to it
um so that um i would suggest going
through each look at that educator's
guide and then i would actually look
through each one of the lessons and
they're pretty straightforward because
they've done a great job at explaining
exactly what they want the student to
learn
that's awesome okay we shared that link
there i know someone else is asking for
a link to that script writing extension
we'll put that in as well
um let's see what else here
um
ooh can we see a finished product i
don't want to violate any of your
students uh confidentiality or pii
but can you give folks a sense of like
what your sixth graders are coming up
with
um well i get a lot of i've been getting
a lot of stories about unicorns and
a lot of pictures of unicorns and uh
things like that
um i wish i could um
i had some of those things but we had we
left before we got to get a lot of the
finished products
but um a lot of the students some of the
students will come up with
amazing narrative scripts about um
things that are happening and and in
their own lives and
and
um
i just i wish i had some to show show
you but um
you're going to be amazed at what you
find and what you guys are going to get
some of the pictures that they draw for
me and then um with the characteristics
you have to draw on the outside the
external and then the inside the
internal and some of the pictures these
guys are sending me they
you could tell they really enjoy it
oh that's awesome and especially right
now i think you know like we've been
talking about the really tough emotions
of this moment
and for students to have an outlet to
share how they're feeling
even if it's through a fictional script
like it's so powerful to be able to get
that out there
yeah
okay um
as far as the scripting piece i don't
know if you'll be able to speak to this
laura but have you heard of anyone doing
something similar on an ipad if they
don't have access to chromebooks maybe a
scripting app or something like that
they you should be able to if you go
into chrome and you're opened up you
should be able to
access the umi screen script on any
device that you have i haven't
had anyone tell me that they haven't
been able to access it because it's an
actual
um app that comes from the chrome web
store so if you haven't um you should be
able to find have it
so it looks like the extension is a nice
thing if you do have chromebooks but
even if you just have a web browser like
safari on an ipad you can still go to
uniscript.com and get started it looks
like
you should be able to do that yeah yeah
great
um
again sort of the question around
um isolation versus whole unit obviously
there's this huge cornucopia of lessons
here
do you think it's okay just to sort of
pick and choose like hey maybe i want to
do a little bit of geometry or a little
bit of stat or is it really better to go
through that full unit of storytelling
well um it's better to go from beginning
to end especially with storytelling now
with the animation um you can
um
the
some of them build upon
the other ones so it's really better to
go in the sequence of what the how the
lessons are provided for you
makes sense yeah i think storytelling is
such a like
um additive cumulative process that you
don't just dip in and out for that one
um
what about this question especially for
younger students so maybe like sixth
graders and below
obviously anytime you have students who
are under 13 there are very specific
policies in place when it comes to
technology do your students actually
have khan academy logins or is that
actually irrelevant every single one of
my kids has khan academy login that's
one thing
um that we have um
emphasized i've been just it's been
incredible to be able to be a khan
academy ambassador because i've been
able to
specifically at my site be able to show
all the teachers how to get on khan
academy how to get um
their classrooms set up
all of that and so they're able to every
single one of our teachers are able to
um use khan academy and they all have
their own accounts on khan academy
great and i'll just mention like i think
that's probably the best scenario in the
sense that that way you can track their
progress using khan academy reports and
things like that
however i know these are very different
circumstances than we're used to and so
if you're just like i want to roll this
out but i don't have time for another
platform another set of passwords
like um like we were just saying a
second ago
you can always come over to google
classroom or whatever your lms is and
just flat out paste the url in anyone
can access it even without a login and
then just say hey send me your finished
product send me your brainstorm send me
your script send me whatever
and then your students get all the
benefit of all this goodness without
having to create another password
another registration process so just
throwing it out there
let's see here
here's a really interesting question
around special education students so
actually we did a session dedicated to
this audience a couple weeks ago which
is one of our most registered sessions
ever
and there's a real concern right now
that i think every student feels like
they're being left behind in some ways
but special education students have
unique challenges that we have to solve
as educators right now
do you think that this program could
work for that audience and drive that
same level of engagement
absolutely um i work pretty closely with
our special ed
team
their
students are and i'll go back to when i
was doing it as an elective i had the
some of the kids that were from sved
that came into my classroom and they
were um going through all the lessons
together with us but we work closely um
together and i absolutely um some of
those kids have great imaginations and
and i think that they can do it without
any any problems
cool yeah it does feel like this is
really happening something pretty
universal in this moment which is our
desire to tell our stories it doesn't
matter where you're coming from or
whatever like this is a chance to really
have that outlet right
cool well i know we're we're at the
bottom of the hour and i want to respect
your time laura because i know you have
your own students to serve
any final words of wisdom that you want
to leave your fellow educators with as
they go off on their own journeys
um i
like i say pixar uh in a box
is
it's just the art of storytelling and we
are going to create a generations if we
continue to use this we're going to
create a generation of storytellers
which i think is going to be fantastic
and um i would just keep plugging away
and the
like i say
is very straightforward
it's pretty easy to use and um you you
just can't imagine the wonderful stories
that you're gonna get from your kids
cool i think that's what we all need a
little bit more of right now
so i thank you for sharing your story
laura and then i wish everyone else
incredible adventures yet to come and
stories yet to be written and please
please please wish you all um incredible
success on that tough road ahead thank
you so much laura thanks to everyone
thank you
you